Okay. Thanks very much for
inviting me here. Um, I'll, uh,
I've kind of organize my
talk into different bits.
So I'll go through the sections,
me and my project, some history,
the events from September the
14th to February 11th. Um,
the event in its reception,
you know,
this is in the discovery
of gravitational waves.
The first confirmed detection of
gravitational waves announced at a press
conference on February the 11th,
2016 but the actual event was seen on
September the 15th 2015 and a few more
things at the end,
which are some of which you might be quite
interesting and I'll head each of the
sections with this.
So we'll see how we're getting along.
I'll try and talk for about 30 minutes
and leave plenty of time for questions
and answers because they
usually all various questions.
So let's start with me and my project.
Um,
it's actually, I've been doing this
for a sick kid. He's the 45th year,
not 30th year at least I started in 1972.
Those were the first interviews I
conducted on what was then the controversy
over gravitation of waves.
Talk a bit there.
I took a bit more about that in a moment.
And these are the, some of the books.
Gravity's shadow, which is a very thick
book. It's about over 800 pages long,
nearly 900 pages, um, which
was published in 2004.
My advice is not to buy it
because once you start reading it,
you'll never put it down and it
will waste a lot of your time.
And the second that that book gravity's
goal is actually two books in one.
Once one book is called gravity's goes to,
which was originally published
separately by itself.
And then the second
book was called Big Dog.
And I persuaded the publisher has to
include gravity's ghost in the publication
of big dog. So this book is the
paperback version of gravities ghost,
as well as being the
paperback version of big dog.
There was never a hardback version of it.
And what that book describes is
to so-called blind injections,
which is what this is when the big
interfere a metric gravitational wave
detectors were in business.
I'll explain that in a moment and what
the scientists did was get a small group,
two or three people to inject
into the interferometers.
A signal worked,
looked like a gravitational wave and keep
it secret so that the whole community
had to investigate this signal not knowing
whether it is a real signal or a fake
signal. So they were rehearsing
for the detection of a real signal,
not knowing whether they were already
looking at a real signal to make it as
valued as possible.
One of the things that the book talks
about a lot is whether these blind
injections were really mimicking a real
detection of gravitational waves because
now we had the real detection of
gravitational, where's the book?
This book is a real time account from
the evening of September the 15th night
2015 when I was first read the email
that said, interesting event
has happened to you know,
for about six months until
the thing was out in public.
And then it goes on about the
reception of it in public and so forth.
It's all written in real time
or mostly real time. Anyway,
I didn't start writing it until the
event happened on a Monday and I didn't
start writing the book and
tell the Thursday because
I assumed it wasn't a real
event, just like every, all the other
scientists did as well. You know,
they thought there's another bit of noise.
Uh,
but then it grew rapidly in
credibility over about two days.
And then I realized, Hey, this is
something interesting going on here.
And I started to write on the
Thursday, um, have just having
collected the emails up till then.
It was obviously interesting
from the word go to collect,
be worth collecting emails, which
I did incidentally, just so you,
I'll tell you how I wrote this book.
I mean,
I've been at this for
donkey's years as you see.
And my method is mostly to initially
to interview the scientists.
I went in 1972 I drove across America
and I'll call talking to all the
scientists are involving gravitational
wave detection. And then from the, uh,
mid nineties to the mid two thousands,
I went to every single gravitational wave
conference that took place around the
world and got to know the gravitational
wave scientists really well.
Uh,
I mean,
one of the very senior people and we
were staying with us for the weekend just
last weekend actually because
we've become friends and uh,
then, uh, but, and so I did
an awful lot of traveling,
use an awful lot of air miles,
enough air miles to travel business
class wherever I went for about 10 years
because I had always air miles, can't
do it anymore unfortunately. Um,
and uh,
so I was going to maybe six,
seven international meetings
a year across the world. Uh,
but this event I assumed was going to
involve me in a hell of a lot of airplane
travel, but it didn't because the
whole thing happened over email.
Email's a few telecoms,
few telephone calls.
Obviously people were talking to
each other and their local groups.
Remember this is a group of,
uh,
1200 people scattered around the world
and they did not at any time during the
course of this discovery
meet together in one place.
They did it all by email and by telecom.
And I was just sitting in the middle
of this web of emails and telecoms
collecting them. Um, the,
the question is why on Earth,
why me?
You want to know if you want to know
something about the detection of
gravitational waves,
why have you invited a sociologist?
I'm a sociologist, for
heaven's sake. Okay.
And this is a fairly
serious question for me to,
am I capable of writing about the
detection of gravitational waves?
And the answer is yes. Uh, and,
but I'm going to justify this a
little bit more than I might normally,
let me say one justification
is that when I write stuff,
I send it to the gravitation
of warf physicists and say,
read this and tell me if
there's anything wrong with it.
And I've never had any serious problems.
Well, you know, we have a few options.
You know, you're saying that about
us, Harry, that's not true. And I say,
well I think it is true
and we argue backwards and
forwards and generally when I
have a serious conversation like that,
I'll alter maybe half of what I've,
half of the points that they object to
and leave. The other half is I wear.
That's the kind of way it goes.
But I'm going to talk a little bit more
about why it is that I am capable of
writing this book because I think one
of the tests I did his particular of
particular interest to you guys.
Uh,
and there you are.
There's a piece in nature.
Sociologists Falls, physics judges,
that's me under sociologist.
And uh,
I did it by playing imitation games,
which of course are the
forerunners of the cheering test.
So I thought you might be slightly
interested in these and what this nature
article is reporting is
something we did in 2005 strokes.
Six where I got a gravitation away,
physicist from my university
departments in Cardiff,
Cardiff is by coincidence.
I shouldn't by complete coincidence,
quite a big place for
gravitational wave physics.
So I've got one of the guys from
their professor from there to ask some
questions of me and to
gravitation wave physicist.
And then we had three dialogues.
You know me the question there,
the answer from respondent, either
the answer from respondent be there.
This was sent to nine other
gravitational wave physicists.
They were technical questions and the
nine other gravitational wave physicists
was or asked which one's the
real gravitation wave physicist.
We've done a lot in Cardiff.
We,
me and my group has done
a lot more invitation game
since since then and we got
to and very nice two and a quarter
million European Research Council advance
grant to use a mutation
games as a new suit,
social science method and we're just
writing a book about invitation came
through MIT press. Uh, and then
we repeated this experiment.
Those are the questions.
I'm just sorry we repeated experiments.
These are the for some much more recent
versions of it in 2016 if you want to
know what the questions were like,
I've given you the 2016 questions
doubles to read through all those eight
questions.
Just pick one or two at random so you get
a sense of the nature of the questions
being asked. This wasn't
trivial stuff. Okay.
This was quite a reasonably hard to sang
professor of physics at Cardiff asked
those questions.
Okay,
okay. And here's the
results of that test. So,
uh,
on the left hand side of the table,
you see that the question is we,
this time we elaborated,
we've got not just me but other people
to answer the questions as not just me
and a gravitational wave physicist.
We've got three gravitation away
physicists to answer the questions.
We got what I call three savvy
Now savvy physicists are astro physicist
working in the same department,
Cardiff Department as the
gravitational wave physicists.
So they knew a lot about gravitational
waves from working in the same department
as well as being astrophysicists
themselves to savvy social scientists.
And savvy social scientists are people
like my junior colleagues at Cardiff who
have to read everything I ever write
and listen to me talking, you know,
enormous length about
gravitational wave physics.
So they know quite a bit about it as well.
And me how Rick Collins and then on the
right we got going across the top you
see the people who mark to the answers,
people who mark the answers where another
four gravitation wave physicist for
different ones entirely.
Okay.
The two sound the same to
savvy social scientists. Um,
you may,
you may have already struck me,
there's a problem here because the
people marking their own answers,
but actually it was in much of it is
less of a problem than you think because
the marketing was done a long time
after the questions were being asked and
there's 72 randomly ordered questions and
it's not actually so easy to recognize
which question you've answered. So it's
a little bit messy but it's not too bad.
Okay. To ordinary social scientists who
knew nothing about gravitation away,
physicist especially cause they
weren't under my control and me myself.
So the first thing to look down is the
left hand column and you'll see the way
the, for gravitational wave physicists,
you could get a maximum of 32 points.
Then if you answered every question right.
And I got the grant other than the three
other gravitational wave because it has
got an average of 27 points and
I got 25 points, which isn't bad.
Whereas the non gravitational
wave physicists,
crucially including the savvy physicists
who didn't know anything about
gravitational waves,
got considerably less points.
And there's an interesting lesson in
this very little small experiment,
which is the,
is that like crevasses?
They're very narrow and deep and it's
not the case that if you're a scientist
and a white coat,
you can go up and pronounce
or authoritatively on any
similar subject as close
to yours.
And this little tiny experiment shows it
and even a snotty nose sociologist like
me can do better in
answering those questions.
Then a physicist who's been spent a lot
of time near to other gravitational wave
physicist, well, there's
more in that table.
We can come back to it in the
question session if you want,
but I don't want to spend a whole
lecture on that. So some history of this,
the first person to have tried
to detect gravitational waves,
Einstein invented or worked out that
these were a consequence of the theory of
relativity in the early 20th century.
He worked out what the,
kind of, not the wave form,
but some of their properties
when he worked out the
general theory of relativity
in 1915, uh, the detection,
which was in 2015,
was miraculously just a hundred years
after Einstein had come up with a detailed
idea, uh, but the first person to
try and detect them with Joe Weber,
this guy here shown here who started
to try and detect them in the,
in the early sixties
with a device like this,
that thing he's working on is a
cylinder of Allah minium wiring, a ton
and a hall for a couple of tons suspended,
insulated in a vacuum tube.
It has PSE electric crystals
glue to its surface,
which will sense any
slight vibration in the,
uh, in the cylinder. And the trick
is to have two of these cylinders,
a couple of thousand miles apart and look
for coincident excitations in the two
cylinders. And what you say as
if this happens, if the, if,
if you've eliminated all sources of
vibration and the cylinders you call them,
they were always juggling a bell from
Brownian motion and residual vibrations
coming up through the earth.
You hadn't quite managed to damp out and
residual 60 mains frequency and things
like that.
It's coming through the electrical system.
But if you can eliminate most of that
stuff and then you see couple of big
excursions happening at exactly the
same time or to be more exact within the
light travel time between the two, 2000
miles on our detectors. Okay. You can,
you say, well I, I can't think
what could have caused this.
So we'll call that gravitation
waves. Okay. Well you,
you can think of some things
that could have caused it.
If you get a lightening strike
somewhere in between the two detectors,
well they could cause it.
And the other thing that,
the sort of thing that people used to
worry about is what if this happens on
Monday night in America when everybody's
watching Monday night football and at
the interval low got up and switch a
kettle kettles on that's going to send a
pulse through the grid at exactly
the same time and that could fall.
You might think that's a gravity wave,
but so you wipe out all that sort of stuff
and you try and measure all that sort
of stuff and you try and
get to a gravitational wave.
Um, that's a schematic of
Joe's Webber's designed,
um,
uh,
another half dozen people tried to
repeat Joe Webb as findings pretty well
completely.
They didn't confirm it.
And that's when I come in in 1972
going around interviewing both lots of
scientists and trying to work out how
they argue with each other and how they
come to a conclusion. That
was my earliest work. Um,
and uh, yeah, let's, let's see
that, so with that technology,
which was improved,
the next generation of these resonant
bars was cooled down to near absolute
zero. Uh, they're quite
difficult, but let's,
it says Joe weapons operators must've
cost a few tens of thousands of dollars,
and then you're getting into the
hundreds of thousands of dollars with a
cryogenically cooled bars,
a big sentence of this virtually,
uh,
as well as the United States.
And over the period up to
the early two thousands,
about half a thousand claims were made
to have detected gravitational waves with
this technology,
but they were all shut down eventually
by the scientific community.
That's an important piece of context
to the discovery when it did happen,
because you've got to realize that when
these people were thinking they were
seeing a gravitational wave in 2015 this
was against a background of nearly 50
years of shooting down every single claim
that had ever been made to have seen a
gravitational wave.
And there was a lot of paranoia
about and a lot of enmity about,
because the rest of the physics community
generally felt that their money was
being wasted by these idiots trying
to detect gravitational waves.
I should add that the should
have said this before,
the point about gravitational
waves, they're very, very,
very difficult to detect.
So how are they produced?
They're produced by moving masses.
So just as electromagnetic waves
are produced by moving electrons.
My fist here is producing gravitational
ways cause I'm moving in about how much,
well,
probably about a quantum of energy in
the lifetime of a couple of universities.
Uh, when Einstein worked out, the formula
for the emission of gravitational waves,
uh,
in the denominator was a
factor of the speed of light.
The power for that just
gives you a sense of how,
uh, difficult to detect these things
are. We'll come back to that in a minute.
Um,
so half a dozen claims were made and the,
and the point is that if Joe Weber
had been right and he'd really been,
didn't detecting gravitational
waves according to the theory,
either something very funny would've been,
must've been going on.
Like there was a very local source,
which we couldn't see.
I mean really local predicting,
emitting the ways he was doing,
he was seeing,
but most people thought the way it ought
to be coming from the center of the
galaxy if he was seeing them.
Um,
or either that or there's so much energy,
Jen energy was being produced in
gravitational radiation that the milky way
should have been burning up before
our eyes and disappearing. Uh,
and people were upset by that idea and
so they didn't really want to accept code
Joe Webb as findings nor any
of the subsequent findings.
So that's the early technology.
Then the technology slowly and
gradually moved over to interferometry.
Um,
an interferometer who doesn't know
what an interferometer his hands up,
okay? An interferometer
is a device with two arms.
There you can see the two arms,
okay? You go from a center station,
you shine light down the two arms.
The light is reflected back
for mirrors at the end.
And then the reflected light is combined
on a screen in the, in the middle.
And if you see that, if that
light is coherent, you will see,
um,
a pattern of light and dark.
So called fringes,
light and dark stripes on the screen.
Okay.
And the light and dark stripes are caused
by the interference of the two beams
of light coming back
and meeting each other.
They're dark where trough and a peak
coincide and cancel each other out.
They're bright where two peaks or two
troughs coincide and double the effect.
So you get these light and dark troughs.
Now supposing you my new increased
the length of one of the arms,
then
okay,
the position where the light light that
said the to the light and dark troughs
we'll meet each other will
be slightly different.
So what you'll see is that that pattern
of fringes move slightly across the
screen. And this is an
incredibly sensitive instrument.
Now I've built one of it.
I bet a lot of these actually myself
just to homemade one and you can do it.
And I'm going to write another book
about gravitation and ways in which I'll
give you instructions on how to do it.
Uh, but it's very, it's pretty easy. Um,
mine has arms about my typical one
has arms about eight inches long.
The source of light is a
laser pointer. Okay. Uh,
the mirrors are just bits
of broken shaving, mirror.
Don't need anything fancy.
You need here a beam splitter,
which should be something
like a semi silvered mirror.
But I've discovered any old bit of glass.
We'll do,
I just use a bit of glass out of
the picture frame for my care.
And you can produce interference fringes,
not nice,
neat lined up ones,
pretty rough ones.
But nevertheless you can
see they are interference,
fringes, light and dark, light,
dark pattern. And you can
test this out. So this,
this little interfere type
of interferometry liabilities
made out of a bit of
chip board as a base. And if you've got
a cup of coffee and put it down on the,
on the base somewhere near one
of where one of the beams is,
the wood will expand and you will see
the expansion of that word as a movement
of the light and dark patches.
And when you take the coffee back,
pick your coffee, cup up, that expansion
will slowly go back again and you can,
then you can put your Coffee Cup on
near the other beam and you will see the
movement of the fringes and in the other
direction and back again and so forth.
So it's quite a nice fun instrument build.
Uh,
I just did that for myself to help myself
be more of a participant in the whole
gravitational worth business though
I once took it to her, a physicist,
a gravitational wave
physicist conference and said,
what do you want to display this?
And they sneered at me
because of course they're interferometer
is a somewhat more sensitive.
The interferometer is used in the
detection instrument are the arms or four
kilometers long.
Okay.
The lasers are extraordinarily powerful
and the light doesn't just bounced for
kilometers and come back.
It bounces backwards and forwards.
It's a hundred times before they recombine
it and so on and so on and so on and
so on. And so on. These things
are, um, probably, I think, no,
I don't say probably
they are the largest law,
the most sensitive large scale
instruments that have ever been built.
It may be the most sensitive
instruments that have been built,
but they're certainly the most sensitive
large scale instruments that have ever
been built.
So that kind of the interferometry took
over from about the early two thousands
or late 1990s and there was a big
war between the people champing the
interferometer technology,
which cost hundreds of millions of
dollars and the people championing the
resonant bar technology, which costs
$100,000. There's a big war between them.
And one of the things I document in my
earlier books is how this war played out
and how they want them,
what happened. But you know,
by now the resonant bars
are almost forgotten. Um,
those are the two big interferometers
in America, one in Hanford,
in Washington state, one
in Livingston, Louisiana.
And there you can see the four kilometer
arms stretching into the distance and
the center station. And it was these
instruments that made the discovery.
Uh,
uh,
there are two generations
of these instruments.
Initial logo was built to about s when
it was taken down about five or six years
ago and they used the same
housings to putting bigger mirrors,
more powerful lasers,
various other things like this better
suspension itself so that it would work
still better.
And that was ready for business in
the autumn of 2015 to February 11th,
February 11th was the press conference,
uh, which you may have seen.
It was all over all the news bulletins
when that gravity waves have been
discovered.
I was up here in London because they
had a little press conference in London.
I went to that and uh,
down in the basement of the building,
we went after it.
We went for a drink and I was
doing high fives or as a physicist,
RSP announcement came up on the
BBC news at six o'clock. Um,
this is the very first email. I
keep writing. September the 14th.
I'm sorry about that.
Um,
that's the phrase high old CWB.
Oh,
I was just put on grace DB, a very
interesting event in the last hour. Okay.
Um, if you want to find out what all
that, all those technical terms mean,
you'll have to read the book. It's all
explained in some detail, but that was it.
Um,
but it didn't excite me particularly.
I just thought, oh, I better
save. I say I've been,
I'm always getting 'em for years been
getting dozens of emails a day from the
gravitational wave community. Every
now and I'm going to think, oh,
that might be interesting.
I'll put them in a separate folder.
But mostly I just delete them
after reading the subject line.
But this one I thought, well,
I'll start putting them in pop,
sort of putting these in their own
folder and see how it fades out. Uh,
and you know,
a couple of months later I just
reaffirmed that I was not the only person
thinking like that.
So you can read that quote from
a gravitational wave physicist.
No, he says, could it have appeared
so earlier the run, it's because the,
the machines weren't
officially switched on.
They weren't supposed to be officially
switched on for another few days.
This was what we've got and what was
going on with an engineering run and they
were still being shaken
down. Uh, as it happens,
that was an extraordinary lucky thing.
On the one hand,
people are data. This shouldn't
happen in engineering run and all.
We are in a position to
make any claim with this,
given that it's in an engineering
run, uh, there'll be too much noise.
Machine won't be steady enough, people
who have been messing about with it.
But it turned out people hadn't been
messing about with it just around the time
and there was just enough sort of period
of smooth noise for them to be able to
do this.
Two,
for that to be enough of that period for
them to be able to do the calculations,
the statistical calculations
they needed to do.
So that's the so early in the run.
But the great advantage of it being so
early in the is that it made it very
unlikely that this was a blind injection
because that's what all the physicists
burger by this time fed up with.
They'd already spent a lot of their
lives analyzing and investigating blind
injections and they didn't want to have
to investigate another blind injection
and they thought,
oh no,
this is the management shoving it in
another blind injection to test us again.
And nobody knows what to do because
if you're seriously investigating
gravitational waves, your
life changes. You know, you,
you stopped talking to your partner
and family on seeing your kids.
You're working like hell
to analyze the data.
And it's even worse for me because
I had written two books about blind
injections, which was a
good thing. Thought that was
fine. I was happy about it,
but there was nowhere I was going to
write a third about a blind injection.
And that meant if it had
been a blonde injection,
I would have been wasting another
three months of my life. Now,
I spoke to the director of the project
and said, look, this is going to happen.
If you put it in another blind injection,
you better tell me because
I can't spend another,
I'm too old to spend another three minutes
of my life messing about with a blind
injection. And he kind of, I think we
had an understanding that he would.
Okay. Um, and then we worked
out how am I going to keep it,
the fact that I know secret from everybody
else and I'll pretend I'm very also,
I can't get on the planes
to fly to meetings,
which I thought would be necessary
at that time. Turned out not to be.
And we said we sorta had a
nod and a wink about that. Uh,
but because it happened
in this engineering run,
most people were ready to believe that
directorate when they sent around an
email saying, no, this is not
a blind injection. I mean,
there's a lot of paranoia.
There were people who still didn't
believe him. I thought that Boston is,
they're trying to test us even more,
you know.
But eventually people decided was
nothing we could do about this.
We've got to get on with the analysis.
And I decided if this turns
out to be a planned injection,
that's the last I'm going to
have to do with lugger. Okay.
But it wasn't a blind injection.
And,
and I was reassured by
the fact five minutes,
I'm going to take a bit longer
than my promised half hour. Okay.
Is that all right? So, uh, uh, I,
uh, it was okay. Then the other
thing that people starting to do,
so you've got this signal, do
you believe it or not? Well,
I will tell you that remarkably,
and this was completely astonishing given
the paranoia that was around that it
only took about two days before people
began to believe this is a real signal.
Once they dismissed the idea of,
you know,
the hadn't yet dismiss the
idea of blind injection.
And the other thing that everybody was
worried about it, was it a malicious hack,
was it some clever,
malicious people from Google
who got into the system and
something which appeared to be a
gravitational wave into the big machines.
And one of the big efforts was to work
out well, what would it take to do?
Is it credible that somebody could
have hacked into it and done this?
And the conclusion was, no, it wasn't.
It would have required to bigger
conspiracy and it couldn't be done.
And people were reasonably satisfied
with that notion though the idea of a
malicious hack or hackers still around
among the fringe scientists who don't
believe this. Um, so that was
another thing that was sent a lot,
spent a lot of time and was then
the analysis starts, you know,
the belief that belief in two days came
because the signal produced a very nice
way for which very nicely matched to
signal from an inspiring binary pair of
black holes.
And the way form overlapped very nicely
on the two detectors to one at Hanford
and the one that Livingston a
couple of sales and miles apart.
And that got people to believe it.
But that's not good enough
for the physics community.
For the physical community.
You have to show that the unlikelihood
of this being due to chance is about one
in three and a half million.
That's the five sigma standard.
There's a whole sociological
story about how that sigma,
how that standard changed in physics from
three sigma and about in the 1960s up
to five sigma in the
earth in Ne two thousands,
which is also discussed in the
book. So, uh, that's the signal.
That's the figure from
the first publication.
That's a sort of slightly simpler and
more easy to understand version of it,
which I got one of the
physicists to draw for me. Uh,
and you can see
how you've got to do a few things. So, um,
that's what the signal from one
of these overlapping, sorry,
inspiring binary neutron stars
ought to look like. Okay.
This is more like what it
would look like on the machine.
You've got to take into account the
sensitivity of the machine and various
different frequencies and these are the
actual signals from the machine and they
overlap very nicely as you can see here.
Okay.
And if you take those that
overlapping signal out,
this is what you got left and it looks
like noise there in lies a story.
Does anybody know I'm doing a piece
of sociological fieldwork now?
Has anybody heard of any recent objections
to the validity of this finding by
Lego? Yeah. Anybody else?
That's one person you've
heard of it? Yeah. Okay.
Yeah.
[inaudible] I really want to know this.
Really put your hands up high because
I want to count one, two, three,
four, five, okay. People
in a room of a hundred.
Yeah. Something like that.
Uh, and what they found out,
the people who are making the recent
objection is they've analyzed this
and they found out that there
is an overlapping signal here.
Okay.
And there is leftover because when the
subtraction was made of this from this,
it wasn't done quite right.
And so there is in fact a bit
of overlapping signal here.
But for some reason please objectors have
decided that the fact that there's an
overlapping signal there means that the
original detection can't be trusted.
Um,
nobody in Lygo thinks this is just in
any way or not a reasonable objection.
And for what my opinion is worth,
I don't think it is either.
But it's interesting sociologically.
Um,
and bears very nicely on the
difference between what you know,
when you're inside a team and what,
you know,
when you're outside of team cause the
objectors or outside the team, you know,
they, they, as most people think,
I don't know how to analyze
their signal properly.
And that goes back to my little
experiment on narrow crow,
vast like nature of science.
Um,
just, uh, the difference between, uh,
how you come to believe in a signal,
which was the overlapping way forms and
what you have to do to prove it to the
wider scientific community.
You could read that quotation from one
of the gravitation away physicists.
They did a little jiggery pokery
with the statistics. It was,
everybody was agonizing.
It wasn't legitimate.
It was this statistical massage concluded.
It wasn't statistical matter. I was,
what they did was okay. Uh, and I
believe it was okay as well. But you,
you see how there, that's a
nice thought about it. Um,
from one of my colleagues in the
gravitational wave, physicists physics,
and you see how people are worried about
it and you see the reason I put up a
quote,
do you want to see the difference between
what makes people believe in something
and what makes people think about what
they have to do to convince the wider
scientific community
the event in its reception?
That's what what was said
at the press conference.
We have detected gravitational
waves. We did it. Uh,
what you,
nobody knew at the time and what I was
stream me sort of cross a bell was that
the reason,
one of the reasons anyway,
that peep the announcement was made with
such a huge confidence is cause by that
time they had already seen
a second gravitation wave,
which hit on boxing day
2015 December the 26th,
but they decided as they hadn't
finished fully analyzing it,
they weren't going to mention it.
The discovery paper,
I thought this was deceitful and it was
falsifying history because the real,
there have been cases in physics
before where a single event,
it turned out to be wrong. The most
famous one is a magnetic monopole.
And the physicists through,
during the course of this whole event,
people were saying, oh, let's hope
this isn't another magnetic monopole.
And then on December the 26th,
the boxing day after a bit
little bit of analysis been done,
a great sort of sigh of relief.
Thank heaven we found a second one,
but that wasn't mentioned in
their discovery announcement,
which would seem to me
to be completely wrong.
Okay.
Uh,
talk to the paper that was the title of
the paper observation of gravitational
waves from binary black hole merger.
And it really did when I was
not in sociological mode,
but getting scientific mode,
sen cold shivers down my spine to
imagine this would happen after I'd been
hanging about for 44 years. This is the
event, billion and a half years ago,
a vision and a half light years away,
two black holes of masses,
36 and 29 solar masses collided
losing three sons with of mass,
which was totally converted
into gravitational wave energy.
Compare that three solar sons
with a mass with about a gram,
a converted into energy
for the first atomic bomb,
five pounds for the biggest
hydrogen bomb that's ever been made.
If the energy had been admitted
as an electromagnetic radiation,
it would have been brighter
than the full moon,
even though it was a bridges and the
half light years away brought in the full
moon for just a fraction of a second.
And if it had happened
that where our son was,
it would have evaporated the solar
system in an instant. But as it was,
the energy was emitted as gravitational
waves. Remember I said how faint it is,
faint gravitational radiation is if
you'd been at a distance of our son from
this huge a mission of energy,
all you would have noticed
would have been a slight
okay
bang in your ears as
your bones in your ears,
but moved slightly by the
gravitational wave passing by.
You wouldn't notice otherwise.
Uh,
the effect on the four
kilometer interferometer
arms changes in the length of
one arm as compared to the other down to
one 10000th of the diameter of a proton
small,
which I worked out and I live in Cardiff,
uh,
that's Cardiff Bay taken from what
was then my study Cardiff Bay.
It's about a square mile of water.
What you were looking for as a
rise in the level of Cardiff Bay,
which would have been caused by the
addition of one 1000th of a drop of water.
And that's why I said it's
the most sensitive instrument
and it's probably ever
been built.
Here's the press conferences
is the newspaper headlines.
There's a song to the tune of,
I'm a believer by some of the physicist.
Uh,
there's a huge spike in Google,
okay.
Which shows that the whole population
has suddenly become fascinated by
gravitational waves but not
as fascinated as they are.
And Kim Kardashian checked
down the same time.
It's about 2% of Kim Kardashians peak
and it completely invisible by Kim
Kardashian's average popularity.
Okay.
A few more things. Uh, how do
we know it's true nowadays?
Well, we don't, but the way
discoveries in physics or social changes
and one of the reasons the social
changes come about is because you,
you know,
when to stop questioning,
there's all kinds of doubts
you can still think up. Okay.
The whole thing depends on trust
and reasonable level of questioning.
On the day of the press announcements,
this was announced in
cern and I listened to the
recording of the announcement
in cern and uh, somebody said,
how do we know that the gravity
waves travel at the speed of light?
Because we don't travel at the
speed of light. All bets are off.
How do we know they travel
at the speed of light?
The whole observation is consistent with
them traveling at the speed of light.
But we don't,
we've never had any real proof.
And somebody put up their hand
for the audiences that, look,
if you carry on questioning like this,
we'll soon have uninvented the
Higgs Boson. Okay. And that's right.
That's the reason you stopped questioning
because if you question deeply enough,
everything collapses and
discovered the Higgs. Um,
then there's,
there's a whole lot of stuff here with
the fringe who are criticizing it.
They didn't the fringe don't believe it.
I was in touch with fringe scientists
and corresponding with them. Um,
and the reason was, well,
I'd better stop actually. I,
well I just don't have time for questions.
We can always come back to these slides
if you want, but I'll stop there.
We do have time for questions.
Please wait for the microphone.
Why did you pick gravitational
waves community to study?
Pure coincidence? Um, I was doing my phd.
I'd already done a study of scientific
communication among people building a new
kind of laser transversely, excited
atmospheric pressure, CO2 laser.
I wanted a more competitive
field to compare it with.
I read about the controversy in the New
Scientist and I thought that'll do me.
I pick one or two others as well
and all that. Is it a community of
sociologists doing quivering book is,
or is it someone embedded in
the Higgs Boson community?
Well, there are sociologists going around
studying, uh, other bits of science.
I'm trying to encourage of this kind
of work to be done because I think it's
very important that people outside of
the technical scientific community have a
really deep understanding of science.
Yeah.
How much does this ups,
the retreat cost and when you take
the whole scientific budget and budget
allocated for the same difficulties
as fundamental assert how much,
how it is I am located for
this particular device.
Okay. Well the whole lot you can say
nowadays by now it's cost about a billion
dollars.
Um,
I don't know how that compares with
the scientific budget as a whole.
One of the problems for the interferometer
was being so expensive that I should
have said they were funded by the national
US National Science Foundation and it
was the biggest experiment in the National
Science Foundation. Had ever funded.
Uh, now, um,
high energy physics is mostly funded by
the Department of Energy and they have a
lot more money.
So the trouble with gravity waves is
it had an impact on the many scientists
doing much smaller experiments
which were funded by the NSF.
So it became very unpopular
among a large constituency.
Um, but uh, when people ask me how
much it costs, I always say, well,
it's probably about the same as
the wing of a stealth fighter.
Compare it with, with military budgets
to put it in perspective. I see.
There must be the similar ones built
all around the world also. Right.
I heard in India is they are
building one there. Yeah.
It didn't make sense to spend that much
money there. Yeah. The Indian, yeah.
One is, is um, the Indian
in India there now,
and it's been a long negotiation
over this, they're building
the infrastructure for it,
the beam tubes and the foundations
and the buildings in India.
But the interferometer parts are coming
from America because when initial logo
was built, they built three interferometer
within the beam tubes for two,
and they're taking the third
one and that's going to India.
Why does it make sense? Well, what
does the whole thing makes sense? Um,
it makes sense because he's a fantastic
confirmation of Einstein's general
theory of relativity. But it also
makes sense if you like astronomy,
because what where it goes is the
foundation of a new gravitational wave
astronomy,
which enables you to see things that
you can't see with electromagnetic
astronomy. So you can pretty well
looked directly at black holes,
which can't be seen any other way.
So this phenomenon that was discovered
this in spiraling of two black holes,
nobody knew if such things existed.
So there were two discoveries,
the first discovery of gravitational
waves and the first discovery of inspiring
binary black holes. Why do
we need another one in? Well,
what the ideal is is to move this
astronomy along so that you can see a
gravitational wave and compare
its position in the sky.
Look at this position in the sky
with electromagnetic telescopes.
And for that reason, you've got
to know its position in the sky.
And the only way to know its position in
the sky is pro by triangulation of the
time of arrival of the event on widely
separated instruments at the moment,
with only two instruments,
you get huge area on the sky
where it could've come from.
There's a third one actually in Italy,
which is just coming online.
And then with indium on,
there'll be four fairly widely separated
and you may be able to narrow down the
position in the sky more narrowly then,
and then your gravitational
story will get better and better.
Yeah.
Um, with hindsight, we
can suddenly tells it,
uh, the first 40 years
of, uh, informative,
uh,
we're clearly not sensitive enough.
Well, if not 40 years of
interferometry is 14 years, 14 years
detectors. Yeah. Um, was
there any acknowledgement of
the time that this might be?
Um, yeah, I mean,
Joe Weber I interviewed in 72 told
me that when he built this apparatus,
he didn't expect to see anything because
everybody knew it was not sensitive
enough. By factor of a, you
know, a thousand million.
Uh, and, uh,
the question is what do you do when you
make you appear to make a discovery,
which ought to be impossible,
do say, oh, forget about it.
It's theoretically impossible or you
say, well, maybe we need to think,
rethink our theories through.
And a lot of people did start rethinking
their theories and find ways to make
Joe Weber's findings
compatible with theory,
like focusing of gravitational
waves by some curious mechanism.
So there's a dilemma there.
And that dilemma was played out and
among the people who put experiment first
and the people who put theory first.
So everybody knew that in theory,
at least in the initial theory,
these instruments were far too
insensitive to see anything.
But the determined experimentalists
still felt well, if I've seen something,
I'm going to report it.
Okay.
Do you see any,
um,
sociological parallels between the whole
field of gravitational waves and people
were kind of on coming on both
sides of it to climate science?
Oh, yes. Um, the, uh, as I said,
I did my first lot of interviews in 1972
and then another lot of interviews in
75,
uh,
7,272 in 1974 I wrote the paper that
emerged out of the 1972 fieldwork and the
big claim in that paper,
the reason I got a university secure
university job and had a stellar career
subsequently was the
observation I made it.
There was something called the
experimenters regress and experimenters,
regressed goes like this.
Uh, scientists say, well,
if you want to know whether something's
true or not, you have to replicate it.
And I think that's correct.
But the trouble is how do you know whether
you've replicated something or not?
So the people who copied
Joe Weber's experiment or
roughly copied it said, look,
we've built an operator's like yours,
Joe, and we don't see anything.
And Joe Weber said to them, that's
because you haven't built it. Right.
And that's not an unreasonable claim
because doing an experiment is very, very,
very, very difficult thing about
day experiments you did at school.
They never worked mostly.
Okay.
You have to be told by the school teacher
that they weren't working and you had
to keep on repeating them
until you got them to work.
And this is what Joe Weber said the
other people needed to be doing. Yeah.
So what happens is if you look at
what happened in 72 and for few years
afterwards, the argument turned
from has this been repeated to
who's competent to repeat it?
Who's the most competent experiment or
is it Joe Weber or is it his rivals?
And then when you get this idea, you see
it happens all the time. Cold fusion,
climate change.
Yes,
you can put this template onto
climate change and it works very well.
I mean, the next problem you have
having done all that is to say,
well how do we come down on the
right side of climate change?
And I'd had been voted in huge rowel
since the early two thousands with my
colleagues because we put forward a view
that we have to shift our attention in
social studies of science from how do
you reach the truth to how do you decide
who's an expert?
And you should always listen to the
experts whether they're right or wrong
because otherwise your society is going
to collapse and you're going to have a
dystopia.
And fortunately my friend Donald Trump
has come along to help my views get
sober.
Thanks very much for your talk.
And I was just curious,
you mentioned before about how black
holes can't be observed, you know,
any other way except
for gravitational waves.
So how did they know when they observed
these gravitational waves that they were
two black holes rotating?
Is it because, um,
they had a theoretical
model of what the garden,
the station Louise would look
like in this kind of matched it?
Or was there some other way that they
knew these black holes were there?
Uh, no. Uh, it's a good question.
Um, so two things. Yeah.
Firstly,
you've got this model which took years
and years and decades to work out,
which didn't match it.
But then at the time people were saying,
but maybe they're not black holes. Maybe
their bows on stars. Bose OnStar's.
Why about the same as
black holes? Okay. Uh,
and but who's ever seen a Bose onstar
we've seen even less than black hole.
This is just a figment of
theoretical physicists imagination.
You can imagine anything and I'm
tearing out my hair saying, oh no,
not those on stars.
We know bows on styles for haven't sake.
Let's have a discovery at last.
I want to die.
Having reported to discovery and the
bows on star sorta thing faded away,
but it's one of those things you
could still ask. You could still ask,
has it really been black hose? And people
could still argue now expose on stars.
It's one of those places where you say
time to stop questioning guys. Okay.
Then
there was another nice little argument
produced for why they had to be black
holes.
They could tell how far apart these things
where just before they collided from
the speed of rotation and they knew how
much they weighed also from that kind of
thing.
And you could work out that nothing
that wasn't very compact could get that
close without touching. And that was
another argument for being black holes.
So it's a good question
because the argument is still
not completely settled but
it's settled
if you're a physicist and you want
to be called kind of reasonably sign.
Okay.
Um, have you now finished
with the gravitational waves
community or what are you
going to do your next?
I don't think anything else is
still going on that you're studying.
That's a very good question. Again,
because I thought I'd finished.
I decided that this was the time
to finish. Nothing is exciting.
This is ever going to happen to
me in my life. Studying again,
my life studying physicist and I've kind
of corralled somebody else to carry on
after me looking at a gravitational
wave physics and continuing to write the
detailed history of it cause I
don't want it to stop suddenly.
But this business about
these guys objecting to it
is really interesting from a
sociological point of view.
So I've found myself getting sucked into
it again and I'll probably write a bit
more about it before I
do completely finish.
Okay.
We are unfortunately out of time. We
have one time for one more question. Oh,
hopefully a quick question then.
Um, so if expertise is very narrow,
going back to your chart at the beginning,
but we should identify the
experts and believe them,
right or wrong is do those two things
make life difficult when you put them
together?
MMM,
I don't think so.
I mean there's another whole element
of which experts you believe in you,
you also have to believe
that only in decent,
honest experts and there's plenty of
non decent dishonest experts around,
but you need a different kind of argument.
I mean there are different kinds of
investigative technique to find out who
those those are. I mean, the,
the instant that I always
use as my touchstone it,
how to think about these
things is the mumps,
measles and rubella
vaccination controversy. And a,
this is one of the things that got me
started in sort of big high to buy lots of
people in social studies of
science because I noticed
that many of my colleagues
in the field wanted to defend the parents,
right?
Not to vaccinate their children during
the course of the mumps, measles,
rubella controversy.
And my view was that was terrible.
And that in fact a parent had
to vaccinate their children.
And the reason is if you,
if you look at what, uh,
Andrew Wakefield, the person who
started the whole controversy said,
if you look at his paper in the Lancet,
I was reading it just the other day
actually, he had no evidence at all
that mumps, measles and rubella
vaccine, we'll link to autism.
There's lots of allusions and
asides in that original paper.
But the paper says we haven't proved
it and he certainly hadn't approved it.
And if you allow a panic
like this to arise,
it was very much a amplified by the
press who have a view that they should
always tell a balanced story. Will
that balanced story? It was about,
yeah,
on the one side we're parents poor
things who'd seen their children become
autistic a little while after
receiving the MMR vaccine.
And the other side of the balance
was the huge epidemiological studies,
which showed that nowhere
where MMR vaccine had been
introduced into countries.
Was there any increase in the
instance of MMR in a population?
And the latter thing is the
end of the story. The parents,
we're always going to see
some children going becoming autistic
after they'd been injected with MMR
because both things happen about same age.
Okay.
And there would be an equal number of
children who nobody would be talking about
who would have re who would have received
the MMR just after becoming autistic,
but nobody was talking about them.
So all this balancing in the
newspapers and so on was wrong.
And one of the arguments that really
infuriated me by one of my colleagues was,
but look,
there might be up there is a possibility
that some small sex subsection of
children who are peculiarly vulnerable
in some way were affected by the MMR
vaccine. The epidemiological statistics
are two large scale to deal with that.
And of course he was absolutely right,
but you could make exactly
the same argument for whether
people became autistic
just after eight in the Kiwi fruit for
the first time or anything else you'd
like.
So if you allow this kind of non-expert
inference from observational statistics
to enter the public domain,
you can waste all your national health
service money on scares and never get
anywhere. I mean the whole argument is
always carried out under the constraint of
scarcity.
And so it's an,
it's not a question of what
absolutely right. In the longterm,
it probably is the case that one
or two kids are vulnerable to MMR.
But it's no good saying it.
It doesn't get you to the policy answer.
So that's my answer to
your question. So, so it,
does that answer your question?
Okay. Thank you very much,
Professor Harry Collins.
[inaudible].